el gobierno turco ha bloqueado esta
mañana el acceso a la televisión pública
alemana deutsche welle y la televisión
pública estadounidense a la voz de
américa en turquía porque estas dos
televisiones no han aplicado a una
licencia para publicar y trabajar en
turquía después de que turquía la
obligas a hacer con una nueva ley
emitida hace unos pocos meses que
obligaba a las televisiones extranjeras
que tienen servicio en turco en
registrarse en turquía y aplicar a las
leyes turcas estas televisiones no han
aplicado estas licencias precisamente
porque aducen que en caso de ser
aplicables a las leyes turcas podrían
ser censurados sus contenidos y
bloqueados los accesos a muchas
informaciones que publican y es algo que
no pueden permitir según ha explicado el
director de deutsche welle que ha dicho
que apelarán contra esta sentencia y que
no aceptarán el bloqueo que de momento
sigue en pie y que puede durar hasta que
termine el proceso judicial en contra de
deutsche welle y la voz de américa
además turquía está trabajando una nueva
ley contra la desinformación según el
gobierno turco que permitiría que la
justicia turca encarcelase a ciudadanos
o periodistas que publicasen información
que fuese falsa o errónea o directamente
desinformación siempre según el criterio
del gobierno de turquía y perdón